[Applause]
Thank You America
so like a six pound frozen block of
in-flight bathroom waste james commis
book dropped from the sky and when it
did the media couldn't contain their
excitement the james comey book
accidentally came out early
oops oh good evening Lawrence oh good
evening Rachel I just welcome the end
because I want to see how the
investigation turns out so it's just
gonna breaking news they can read I kid
now no one no one sent me a book
everyone else got one and it made them
feel so funny inside Comey went further
than you were even expecting even more
so than what he talked about in the book
he is just not holding back
I'm president Truong in any way shape
and he talks about how it was the
out-of-body experience for him to sit
with the president it must have been an
out-of-body experience for you thank you
for saying that
kids this ain't the Bible it's a freakin
book of gossip by a bitter ex here's one
revelation though Comey says Trump
reminds him of something mm-hmm him
I thought of New York Mafia social clubs
the Italian mafia called itself lacasa
notes La Cosa Nostra this thing of ours
and always drew a line between someone
who was a friend of yours meaning
someone outside the family and someone
who was a friend of ours meaning an
official member of the family the
president-elect was trying to make us
all part of the same family and that
team Trump had made it a thing of ours
so I'm pretty sure that Thursday night
Rachel read the entire book to her
audience it was like a bedtime story for
communist party cat ladies
but Trump's like a mafia boss file that
under duh anyone who saw the debates
knows that everyday put out a hit on a
rival the fact in fact is he's a
billionaire real estate developer in New
York City you think he never had to deal
with actual mafia bosses why do you
think he's the way he is now sorry when
America hears Comey whine that Trump is
like a mafia boss they go no Sherlock
that's why we like him think about it
who would you rather have dealing with
the likes of North Korea or Putin a guy
who reminds you of this or someone who
reminds you of a grad school TA who
reads poetry to his cat now if
I don't know that he does that
okay if I were Trump when asked about
being called a mob boss I'd say I'm
deeply flattered then I would hand out
red hats that say mafia instead of manga
we had that made by the way $25 if you
want it bottom line this all comes down
to one fact there's a certain kind of
person designed to be president from the
get-go they look like this or this or
this Trump's not them
he's Trump someone unaccustomed to the
purity test all politicians can fake
which is why the public doesn't care
they know what he is he may be a mafia
boss but he's our mafia boss they're
applauding for the Mafia they are
applauding for the Mafia so while the
media spews crap how does America feel
about it all of this is about behavior
prior to an election designed to unseat
a president based on a vast emotional
injury that occurred on November 8th
2016 what unites anti-trump errs is PTSD
President Trump
stress disorder the media says Trump is
using foreign policy to distract from
scandal but it's actually the opposite
these scandals are designed to keep him
from doing his job that's how America
sees it that's how I see it and I am
America
yes I am
I've got it I'm kind of shaped like
America and America just wants him to
keep doing his job because so far any
bad Isis North korea-china taxes stop
him now what a story that would be first
an outsider is elected to disrupt the
system second he actually disrupts the
system third the media and their
democratic enablers flip out for they
use everything in their power to remove
him now if they succeed they will have
removed one of the most radical
political figures in recent memory using
behavior that occurred prior to the
election anti-trump errs have you
thought this through if you're not
careful you're gonna turn Trump into a
massive folk hero and seventy million
people will be at your doorstep it'll
won't be to sing you've got a friend
let's welcome tonight's guests like my
favorite butcher Steve she cuts through
the Bologna Homa said something else
father TV host Jedediah Bella like a
well-oiled shopping carts he'll have you
rolling in the aisles actor writer
comedian Jamie LaSalle
she's got more baggage than a Samsonite
salesman natural review reporter cat Tim
and he hates ceiling fan true impact
wrestler to my massive sidekick Tyrus
did a guy a lot happened this week call
me call me call me call me call me what
do you make of this I mean the book
sounds terrible I didn't get a copy
either I can't imagine why but every
excerpt I read made him less and less
likeable as a person and and this guy I
mean he Stoops to the lowest levels he's
like talking about Trump's tie yeah he's
talking about Trump's under-eye circles
like is he in a tanning bed is he not
and it's just like any any shred of
credibility that this guy had which I
don't know how he could have any after
not in dining Hillary Clinton frankly
but any shred that remains has been lost
just from the excerpts that I've read
and it's just you know I think there are
some people in this world that just want
to be in front and center in front of
the camera all the time and we work in
the television business we're trained to
spot them this guy is one of them any
opportunity like someone hand him a show
just because he's begging for it that's
what he wants that would be what tires
you better not
what you better not I warned you about
the Hillary on Sunday Comey gets one I'm
done okay here's my here's my Sunday
lineup by sunday lineup you've got you
got Hillary at 8 o'clock because that
provides fodder for Fox & Friends the
next day followed by Comey and it's like
comité that's called the Comey
confessional and he just tells you what
he thinks sorry Cyrus alright Jamie
Gries under the Comey confessional what
about the Fredo files
because the thing before yes a Godfather
illusion I believe it was what do you
make of Trump's response to Comey I
honestly thought maybe he even
overreacted like why even respond to so
much thank you it is it you're welcome
it is a tell-all book rarely do people
release a tell some book it's it's all
of it and I thought that the whole thing
about I thought Trump should have almost
just just let it roll off his shoulders
especially think about you know the
story that was in there about the Russia
and the prostitutes and the p-type
peeing
I thought sharp should've at least made
an excuse and just said it's not what
everyone thinks it's just I just don't
speak fluent Russian they completely
misunderstand me I was like what are you
guys doing I said there's a leak in the
sink that would work right I said you
get three hot plumbers a three hot
process it's very good cat what do you
make of this of the Comey book there is
nothing wrong with reading poetry to
your cat right that's what you got from
this that's what I just got from your
monologue you seems like you're
insulting one of my favorite past-time
that was actually put in there directed
to insult I thought so yes but no I
agree with Jedediah he made the G made
comments about the tiny hands
yes are we done with the tiny hands yes
that's like the biggest hack joke in the
world yes I'm surprised like the next
sentence wasn't why didn't the chicken
cross the road
that's how hack that it was it's like
you're not Regina George you are a
former FBI director you can act like a
grown-up
yes wants to be rigid he wants to be
Regina George George Mean Girls oh well
I did not know that
I'm so glad you asked everything I was
nodding just pretending that was afraid
the camera was on me - historical
political figure I'm so embarrassed
Tyrus what do you make of the whole
thing the other dude what's wrong with
having a mafia boss as a president well
as long as your name isn't Fredo yeah
not too bad the whole thing here's the
thing obviously from the day they met
Trump in a coma he did not like each
other yeah it's not a match made in
heaven and he felt he was fired by
someone who was inferior to him so
that's where the anger comes from but
I'm willing to suggest if we actually
got our hands on the book that wasn't
cut and pasted hmm
by the liberal media that it might be a
better read I think I think they're
doing a disservice by outlets I haven't
seen the book but they're taking pieces
out and forming it for the only thing I
think they're making him they're not
you're doing a horrible disservice
Tacoma yeah because you haven't read the
but I haven't read I'm not saying he's
obviously bitter listen if I got fired
by say it was a guy's smaller than me
but I could beat up or whatever I might
I might I might when my book comes out
say some terrible things about like his
animal choices that aren't real or you
know put stools around the office I trip
over all the time I might have some
issues with some things which I get I
understand that we've all been fired and
no I've never said when after I got
fired that was really wonderful play so
I was really glad yeah sorry they fired
me you know I'm saying so I feel like
this is more than mediate like let's
take this one thing I must say this and
let's say this I'll wait till I'll
actually read the book and I'll I would
totally buy that except that when you
watch him in the interviews he's
insufferable yes yeah it's like a pity
party for collagen it's oh my god I
didn't know what to do when he started
talking about his wife said shut up
you're an adult no he he obviously
that's the question that $5.00 should
have asked him do you hate Donald Trump
yeah tell the truth he got under your
skin and you couldn't believe that what
he thought being an elitist yeah this
guy could fire me and that's why we have
so much good stuff in this show to make
her head explode not that I want to see
that because that would be gory and
disgusting